po moves in a variety of different ways
and sometimes it moves in ways that we
can only describe as a pattern so let's
take a look at some really popular ones
Drex here from Drex Factor poy sharing
with you the love of Po spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today I want to dive into five of my
favorite POI patterns yes five more of
them and there's a Twist to how this
list is arranged but before we dive in I
just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyate light toys
spinballs and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
awesome companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non- buus
friend of the channel Becca Becken thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission so I've
already covered five of my favorite POI
patterns that I'll go ahead and link to
down in the description as well as up in
the cards that all have one thing in
common they are POI patterns that
primarily work by thinking about them in
terms of the shapes that the POI follows
as it moves around in space creating
cool Trails but that's not the only way
that I think about POI patterns and I
think it's probably not the only way
that a lot of people think about POI
patterns sometimes you put together a
series of Po movements and you can't
point to just one thing in there that is
a trick and you also can't point to
anything in there that's necessarily a
shape so there's kind of this weird in
between that these POI patterns occupy
and those are the patterns that I want
to talk about in this video so go ahead
and strap yourselves in and pull out
your own set of poy and see if you can
follow along with these five
picks pattern number one horizontal
stacking goodness so this is absolutely
the pattern that launched an entire
framework of petrix this pattern first
appeared in Ivan Mel gorbin off's
Landmark Techo video red pants and it
set a whole flurry of tech poy Spinners
all over the world Off to the Races see
a lot of us realized that the pattern
that Mel was working with there had a
lot of individual pieces that you could
mix match cut copy and paste in a
variety of different orders and it wound
up giving rise to an entire framework of
new petric in particular Leo aaza put
together one of the most comprehensive
videos on this topic which I'll go ahead
and link to in the description but this
was the pattern that started us all off
and it is still one of the best examples
of this type of Po move and speaking of
patterns that became unexpectedly
popular the next entry on this list is
one that was created by somebody who
quite frankly could have a lot of
entries on this list but I had to pick
just
one pattern number two Kate's
combo so for those of you who don't know
Kate McCoy is one of those absolute
Legends of the tech poy world who
managed to be so incredibly successful
specifically because she could outthink
just about any guy out there in the tech
poy world and this pattern in particular
was one that she did frequently and a
lot of us absolutely loved it involves
switching back and forth between two
different timing and Direction modes
while also engaging in stalls along the
way it's a pretty easy idea to
understand but it's deceptively
difficult to actually do it in practice
to say nothing of the fact that Kate is
just one of those spinners who is so
incredibly clean in everything that she
does she made you not just find this
pattern fascinating but really really
really want to do it as cleanly as she
could of course this pattern has both
ins Spin and anti-spin variations my
personal favorite of course is the in
spin one and maybe in another video
we'll take a look at the anti-spin one
but I figure sharing is caring and this
is a pattern definitely worth sharing
okay so hopefully it is becoming more
and more clear that in my mind patterns
is a very encompassing term and so this
list is going to get kind of weird in
fact the next entry is going to get
super weird trick number three the
Fantastic Four the Fantastic Four is
part of an entire family of poy tricks
that revolve around bouncing the POI
around different surfaces of the body
while both POI are being held by the
same hand perhaps the most famous
example of this family is the one-handed
Superman but I'll confess that I think
the Fantastic 4 is a much more
interesting p pattern if for no other
reason then it kind of breaks my ability
to describe what exactly is happening
with the poy in the course of it is this
bouncing back and forth between a pair
of cork screws is this a diagonal plane
move what exactly is the pattern that
each poy is doing as it's going up and
around the entire thing is just kind of
a mish mash of different stuff that
shouldn't work but somehow does I also
love that this is a trick that has so
many applications I've taught this not
only to pois Spinners and glow stringers
but also to meteor Spinners as well as
people that spin orbits it's a
surprisingly versatile move and well
let's face it it looks cool as hell all
right so we've covered patterns from poy
Masters such as Mel and Kate McCoy are
there other Masters out there from whom
we have learned an incredible amount of
cool poy patterns why yes in fact there
are pattern number four
udalls now I doubt most people think of
this as a PO pattern so much as a
framework within which a bunch of
different po patterns can work but I
disagree because I think that all the
different patterns kind of blend
together to a certain extent into
something that we all expect when we see
this move see really when it comes right
down to it you is combining together
plane breaking as well as some great
pero at work creating something that
isn't just eye-catching but also
actually moves through the space in a
way that most poy moves don't and yall
know how much I love my PO dance you
udalls were probably the first POI
patterns I ever learned that actually
forced me to learn some degree of poi
dance there's really no other way to
engage with them add to that the fact
that there's at least three or four
different families of petrix on display
in just this one pattern I think it's
pretty cool that you'd have found
something that was at once so incredibly
simple and eye-catching but at the same
time so incredibly complex on a
theoretical level so very early on in
the PO world all right so if you've come
this far I have a quick favor to ask
before I show you my last pick see if
you come this far I'm pretty sure that
my deductive reasoning has revealed to
me an important truth about you you like
poy tricks and maybe po spinning in
general and if indeed that's the case I
make lots of videos on those topics so
if you wouldn't mind please give the
channel a subscribe or ring the bell and
if you do that you'll be one of the
first to know when I upload a new video
and all of us win so without further Ado
my final pick for my favorite po pattern
is
is pattern number five stall
Chasers so this was informally labeled
the trick of the Year back in 2009 and
there's a reason for it everyone wanted
to learn it now technically speaking
this is actually a UDA move as well he
was seen performing it in wheel plane
instead of wall plane and somebody got
the bright idea of switching the planer
orientation of the pattern and as it
turned out they gave rise to what has
become one of the most ubiquitous po
patterns of all time in the process
process like seriously I remember a year
where every single fire Festival I went
to had people trying to learn how to do
this outside of the classes it came
about and became so popular so quickly
nobody could even put together a
workshop on it and it's easy to see why
the amount of fine control that it takes
over your stalls in order to pull this
one off is really intense we have that
lovely little anti-gravity moment going
across the top where the PO lineup just
so I I've always loved this as a trick
for showing off virtuosity with stalls
and with momentum control and that's why
it's my final pick for five more po
patterns that you want to know what did
you think of this list would all of
these patterns have wound up on your own
list or are there some patterns that I
missed that you think should have been
included I do know that Kate had her own
variation on those stall Chasers that
was really really popular for a while
but I figured I had to go with the
original on this what did you think of
that choice let me know down in the
comments
[Music]
this video would not have been possible
without my amazing supporters on patreon
in particular I would love to give a
shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right now if you like
these videos there's an easy way that
you can make sure that I make more of
them and that is to to go sign up to
support them over on patreon you can do
that at
patreon.com Factor po I will include a
link down in the description as well as
up in the cards if you are watching on
YouTube supporting these videos means
that I get to spend more time in doing
so rather than doing other things that
brings money in the front door so if you
like these videos and you want to see
them continue and you want me to
maintain this level of quality or better
go sign up please and thank you are you
interested in seeing five more po
patterns I absolutely love excellent I'm
going to go ahead and link to another
video that I did that features po
patterns that are centered around the
trails that poy leave behind as they
swing through the air on screen as well
as I will link to it down in the
description thank you so much for
watching make sure to get out and flow
to day yourself and I will see you with
a brand new video real soon take care
and have a good one peace